bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france qu'est ce que vous répondez à cet
argument selon lequel la priorité et
l'urgence des matières premières avant
l'enjeu des brevets mais l'enjeu face à
cette pandémie mondiale
c'est d'abord de faire en sorte que tous
les pays qui demandent de pouvoir
produire ce vaccin puisse le faire
il y à l'inde l'afrique du sud le
sénégal le maroc l'égypte où il y a des
capacités industrielles disponible mais
qui ne sont pas mobilisés aujourd'hui
parce que justement il ya cette
propriété intellectuelle qui pèse et que
les les big pharmas fighter modern
astrazeneca johnson & johnson protège
jalousement et quelque part ils
organisent une sorte de pénurie mondiale
ils font jouer la loi de l'offre et de
la demande et met tous ces pays en
grande difficulté alors que nous
devrions être tous unis pour produire ce
vaccin dans tous les pays du monde et
faire en sorte que tous les peuples
puissent y avoir accès c'est le seul
moyen de lutter contre cette pandémie et
d'empêcher l'apparition de variants et
donc c'est c'est normal c'est bien je
salue véritablement la proposition de
joe biden qui est différente de celle de
donald trump et enfin l'union européenne
et la france réponde positivement ils
vont eux aussi demandé la levée des
brevets ce qui n'était pas le cas
jusqu'à y encore quelques jours sur la
question d'innovation qui risquerait
d'être mise à mal est-ce qu'il ya raison
de s'en préoccuper aujourd'hui enfin
quand même c'est big pharma les files
heures moderna et compagnie ont
bénéficié de milliards
den publique de la part des états unis
de l'union européenne de la france de
l'allemagne pour justement accélérer la
recherche sur les vaccins mais aussi
pour pouvoir les produire massivement
nous avons accompagné la modernisation
de cette industrie pharmaceutique
l'augmentation de leur capacité de
production avec de l'argent public donc
il est normal qu'aujourd'hui les états
demandent à ces industriels de pouvoir
de lever la propriété intellectuelle
pour que nous puissions les produire en
masse aujourd'hui seuls 43% des
capacités industrielles mondiales son
mot
10 et pour la production de vaccins ce
n'est pas normal il nous produisons nous
allons produire 8 milliards 5 de doses
de vaccins cette année alors que
l'objectif c'est 15 milliards pour
pouvoir assurer la vaccination de tous
donc il faut accélérer le mouvement
chaque semaine perdue est une semaine
que nous perdons pour la vie et donc
c'est pour ça que l'échéance du 8 et 9
juin à l'om c'est l'organisation
mondiale du commerce et c'est à cette
date là que sera prise la décision
cette échéance elle est déterminante
pour l'avenir de l'humanité pour pour
notre combat pour la vie il faut que le
8 et 9 juin il y ait le consensus le
plus large des etats-unis de l'union
européenne pour la levée des brevets et
que l'enfant
enfin nous accélérions la production de
ces vaccins emmanuel macron s'est
déclaré ce matin tout à fait favorables
pour reprendre ses termes à la levée des
brevets sur les vagues sans lui qui la
voyait il est encore peu comme un
dernier recours
c'est un retournement rendue possible
par la proposition américaine
oui alors d'un côté je me félicite
qu'enfin la france et que le président
de la république s'engage dans cette
voie là mais je regrette qu' il ne le
fasse que aujourd'hui et en étant à la
remorque eu des états unis j'aurais bien
aimé que mon pays la france sorte de la
tutelle des big pharma est justement
appelle elle aussi à la levée des
brevets et notamment je pense à tous les
peuples d'afrique qui sont aujourd'hui
en attente de pouvoir aussi avoir accès
au vaccin
donc nous aurions d or de pouvoir faire
cette proposition mais bon ce qui compte
maintenant c'est on accélère il faut
pouvoir mais l'industrie pharmaceutique
sous la tutelle des nations les peuples
ce n'est pas à eux de commenter la
production des vaccins de fixer les prix
c'est au pays aux états qui ont
largement financé cette recherche devoir
dire où et combien donc vendre des
vaccins mais c'est un ami aux états de
prendre la main sur cette lutte contre
cette pandémie
le patron de l'om est sans appel à une
telle mesure
déclarant en gros aux dirigeants des
pays riches si vous ne faites pas par
philanthropie fait le par intérêt on ne
se débarrassera pas du coït si tous les
pays n'ont pas accès à la vaccination
c'est ce que vous sous-entendez là aussi
oui parce que bon vous savez que les
variants apparaissent quand nous tardons
à vacciner massivement la population
c'est quand le virus est présent
longtemps dans un pays dans un bassin de
vie que se développent des variants donc
il y à une urgence temporel il ya une
urgence à vacciner massivement pour
empêcher l'apparition de nouveaux
variants c'est pour ça qu'il faut
permettre à tous les pays du monde
en même temps d'avoir accès à ces
vaccins pour pouvoir lutter efficacement
contre le virus et l'apparition de
nouveaux variantes
je regrette que des pays comme la france
mais les pays de l'union européenne ue
etats unis en ont fait un enjeu
géopolitique
au départ ils n'ont pas voulu la levée
des brevets parce qu'il voulait empêcher
la chine et la russie d'avoir accès aux
brevets enfin aux vaccins et aux
différentes sortes de vaccins notamment
arn messager aujourd'hui il faut sortir
de ces querelles de ces guerres entre
pays la seule le seul combat qui doit
nous unir c'est de permettre à tous les
peuples du monde d'avoir accès au vaccin
parce que c'est comme cela que nous
arriverons à vaincre cette pandémie il
faut unir nos forces unies en eau
énergie travail et faire travailler
ensemble les chercheurs mobilisés tous
les sites de production il faut former
des centaines de milliers de salariés à
la production de ces vaccins
c'est ça l'enjeu merci beaucoup d'avoir
réagi sur notre antenne fabien roussel
d'épuration secrétaire nationale du
parti communiste français